ROCKET
Why are we always getting involved
in everyone else's troubles?
[Laughter]
PETER QUILL
Because we're the freaking Guardians of the Galaxy.
(Crank up the volume
for the summer's biggest event.)
GROOT
I am Groot.
GAMORA
You're all just making up stuff
that he's saying, right?
ROCKET
No!
DRAX
Analogy.
PETER QUILL
Is it?
DRAX
Metaphor.
MANTIS
Oh...
PETER QUILL
If this is the end,
may as well have
a little fun, huh?
DRAX
Yeah! [Laughing]
♫ Hooked on a feelin' ♫
MANTIS
Hello!
[Screaming]
PETER QUILL
Exactly!
NEBULA
You left out some important information
but, that is the gist of it.
[Screaming]
♫ Hooked on a feelin' ♫
MANTIS
I was screaming at something scary
behind you, not you,
you look really cool.
LAMBSHANK
Thank you!